a third woman now accuses new york
governor andrew cuomo of harassment
adding to the claims of inappropriate
behavior by
the three-term democrat his first two
accusers are former staff members
as national correspondent jerica duncan
reports the new accuser
says it happened at a wedding anna ruck
told the new york times she never met
governor andrew cuomo before
this night at a september 2019
wedding ruck said she was discussing the
governor's toast
when instantly he put his hand on her
bare lower back
she removed his hand with her own the
next moment is captured here
when the governor placed his hands on
her cheeks he asked if he could kiss her
loudly enough for a friend standing
nearby to hear
the now 33 year old said she was
confused and shocked
and embarrassed this is the third
allegation of sexual harassment against
cuomo
he has not responded to the new
allegation but in a previous statement
the three-term governor said that he
never inappropriately propositioned
anyone
but rather his comments were attempts at
being playful
and apologize to anyone who
misinterpreted his actions
on twitter the two other accusers added
their support for ruck
lindsey boylan saying she feels nauseous
thinking about anna's experience
and charlotte bennett saying his
inappropriate and aggressive behavior
cannot be justified or normalized
earlier yesterday bennett rejected the
governor's attempt to apologize
accusing him of refusing to acknowledge
or take responsibility for his predatory
behavior
this comes as the state attorney general
leticia james announced
she is officially moving forward with an
independent investigation
into cuomo's alleged actions after
receiving the correct paperwork from the
governor's office
now several democrats and advocacy
groups have called for the governor to
resign
amid the allegations and that
investigation will be the second one
looking into cuomo's office this justice
department is also probing as to whether
or not the state's
and accurately reported some nursing
home deaths in the state we also learned
that the governor has hired a criminal
defense attorney
to represent him and others in his
office into those federal
inquiries gail all right jericho thank
you